pai qui nous attend merci madame la
parole et à monsieur jacques alain
bénisti
merci monsieur le président je vais
associé à ma question
l'ensemble des parlementaires
républicains de paris et d'île de france
ma question s'adresse malheureusement
monsieur le premier ministre il est pas
là n'en déplaise à madame touraine en
1966 et le des générals de gaulle qui
inaugurait les voies sur berge cette
prouesse
infrastructurel qui allait permettre
enfin de désengorger le centre de paris
de ces véhicules a nommé siècle plus
tard mais avec dix fois plus de
véhicules
la maire de paris décide sans aucune
concertation et faisant fi de l'avis
négatif du commissaire enquêteur de
fermer cette voie pour en faire une aire
de détente pour les parisiens résultat
des milliers de véhicules qui
l'utilisaient sont reportés sur les
grands axes et sur les voies adjacentes
créant une véritable thrombose dans le
centre de paris et je ne vous parle pas
des conséquences dramatiques de nouveaux
pics jamais connu de pollution de l'air
consécutif à l'augmentation des
embouteillages car c'est ce sont les
embouteillages qui provoque les
pollutions intensive
la maire de paris agit là en despote
alors qu'elle connaît parfaitement
l'état de délabrement des transports en
commun totalement saturée déficient
insalubre résultats de 17 années
d'inaction de la région de même la
saturation totale des axes routiers
particulièrement dans l'est parisien ne
laisse plus aucune alternative aux
habitants des banlieues pour venir
travailler à paris alors monsieur le
premier ministre fasse un grand paris
martyrisé face à un grand paris sclérosé
face à un grand paris asphyxiés c'est à
vous maintenant que le libérer
la parole et à madame ségolène royal
ministre de l'environnement de l'énergie
et de la mer si monsieur le président je
serais moins lyrique que vous je pense
que vous attendez de réponses concrètes
et pas forcément pas forcément le
lyrique il ya quelques instants nous
avons évoqué l'accord de paris sur le
climat qui avait vu le record du délais
de ratification de cet accord il ya
encore deux mois c'était 2 % de
participation nous allons franchir dans
quelques heures les 55 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre c'est à dire des
pays qui veulent réduire la pollution et
si on veut réduire la pollution il faut
que les villes s'y mettre et la maire de
paris anne hidalgo a eu ce courage
c'était dans son programme municipal
elle l'a fait voter au conseil de paris
elle a eu ce courage en effet de
repenser la ville par rapport à la
pression de des voitures qui circulent
avec l'énergie fossile alors je voudrais
vous dire que dans son arrêté municipal
il est explicitement prévu qu'il y aura
une évaluation par conséquent j'ai
demandé que cette évaluation s'accélère
c'est le préfet de police qui est
compétent pour cela il réunira la
semaine prochaine le comité technique
tous les parlementaires pourront y être
associée les documents que le ministère
dans le ministère dispose par rapport à
cet impact sur ont mis à disposition de
cette commune de cette commission
technique la présidente de région m'a
d'ailleurs saisi à ce sujet là et il est
on verra les choses il ya toujours de
toute façon une phase d'adaptation
lorsque l'on modifie les comportements
mais il est évident que toutes les
villes ont intérêt quand même à diminuer
la place de la voiture en ville en
développant d'autres méthodes de
déplacement du co voiturage du transport
électrique et caetera et je pense que
sur ces sujets là il faut vraiment
puisque la france a ratifié l'accord de
paris puisque la france a été à
l'origine de cet accord mondial
exceptionnel dans un temps record nous
devons vraiment tous ensemble aller dans
la même direction
merci madame la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue